I'm not afraid to kiss a mom shoulder
[Music]
sorry this movie we can't be having a
non Leonardo DiCaprio moment what's it
what's a non oh I have to be fully star
powered yeah no that's not my Bob that's
supposed to happen in fact a bird is
just supposed to do on me we could say
congratulations this is such a cool
moment for you um tell us about the
movie and what it's like to have Rose
burn in your ear and acting with her but
she's not actually there yeah I mean it
was a trip well Jack see it's a it's a
movie about your phone and how it's
ruining our lives and one day they'll
they will take over we haven't gone
viral since yesterday prison lives what
do you got cats that look like Ryan
Gosling
I like you I like you lag ruin your life
what do you spend the most time on like
apps games shopping texting friend I
found myself just staring at it like
just staring just I'll just like fall
into a Instagram vortex and I'll never
get out but everybody has something
everyone's looking at something have you
ever sent a text or a picture to someone
and regretted it instantly like an
accidental text oh you know what
happened one time my my girlfriend or my
sorry yes what happened one time was
this girl who I was sort of seen sent me
a photo of her like this just shirtless
just covering her stuff like this so I
send back a photo to her covering myself
like this except for I sent it to
Britney my little sister instead so and
things like that can happen be careful
who you send you're sexy you're tasteful
nudes at least it was tasteful with you
so it all worked out I guess she
immediately hit me back and she was like
what is going on never send me things
like this you're trying to land a date
why now I know the answer to this you're
trying to land a date what's your
texting do's and don'ts to like get a
date through text get a date through
text a lot of you UPS girls love that
oh they love stuff like that you look at
your phone differently now that you've
shot the movie you know I didn't think I
was addicted until I shot the movie and
then as I'm shooting the movie I'm
talking to a phone in the movie while
doing scenes and then immediately as
soon as we're done with the scene I pick
up my phone and stare at it until it's
time to pick up the other phone and I'm
like you did spend some time punching
our America's Sweetheart Justin Hartley
in this movie and I'm not okay with it
Adam actually I met quite angry at you
what was it like to pant to punch such a
beautiful man hey I guess there's a new
heartthrob in town sorry Justin
you boosted pictures of your junk to
everyone Carol's pretty psych
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]